[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's dwayne wade three-time nba champ
turner sports nba analyst and has a new
book out a photographic memoir it's
called dwayne it's released today
featuring never before seen photos from
his life on and off the court and uh of
course he's doing a whole lot since uh
he stopped playing basketball you know
what duane we talk about lebron as a
high school football player nobody ever
talks about you in your high school
football career why why is that at
richards high school what kind of player
were you
it was short lived dad it was very
it was about a two three year run it was
very short-lived okay but uh are there
any highlights
uh you know what i i believe i was i
thought i was a better football player
than i probably was like in my mind i
was like i was the next randy moss but
really i probably wasn't that good
did you mind getting hit
i didn't it wasn't my favorite thing
you know like
you're not waking up saying i want to
get hit like it wasn't my favorite thing
to do at all so
i chose the right sport
your attack mode when did you start
attacking the basket
well i've always i've always done that
you know when i when i was younger i was
so small
and you know i couldn't get my shot off
over a big guy so i had to use my speed
and my quickness so
um that's the only way i was able to
score or play with my dad or my brothers
or my uncles so i always had that
who did you model your game after when
you were younger
dan growing up in chicago michael jordan
i mean you know the greatest player you
know in my generation in my time and to
be able to grow up in in chicago and be
able to tune in to wgn news and to be
able to watch my favorite player uh
night in the night out i mean every move
he did and everything he you know he
said how he walked i tried to emulate
everything
but at what point do you realize you
can't be michael that style um
i mean i i just kept trying i i feel
like if you know i say this in my book i
feel like if you reach for the stars i
mean if you reach for the moon you'll
come down with a few stars and so you
know if i shoot to be someone on the
level of michael jordan um
then me falling short of that is still
still pretty high up
what is the picture in the book that
brings out emotion is there one that you
would say whenever i look at that photo
it elicits something
yeah it's the photo um in the first
quarter of my book where you will see
the building that i grew up in
um it's on 59th and prairie and when i
look at that photo just all the
all the moments of my life comes comes
rushing back you know all i can think
about
is little dwayne you know i could think
about duane and i could think about uh
everything that his family you know was
going through everything that he he went
through everything he's been through
and and to be here right now so i can
look back at that photo
and i could be proud of my journey but i
also could look back at the photo and
see the responsibility in my journey uh
because i know that there's other you
know young duanes out there
that needs the same thing i needed and
they need that
that idol that vision that image
because you make a wrong turn turn you
you make a wrong decision like like
you're
it's different where you grew up you
know if you if you make the wrong choice
you know it could be something really
serious something really bad
did you have sort of somebody who was
watching out a guardian angel watching
out for you
i feel like
i feel like i've had so many
so many um guardian angels in my life
you know i i've watched my my mother and
i talk about in my book i watched my
mother
take the wrong step or take a step that
just it took a while to get back from
you know i mean it's like i can't say
it's the wrong step because it's the
step in her journey and her path um that
you know that i needed to be able to
to take the different step you know like
okay i'm not going left i'm going right
um but we all have those moments right
we all have those moments where we take
a step and sometimes it takes us a
little longer to get back up and get
back on the right path and so for me as
a father that's been my main goal my
main goal has been how do i help you
know as much as possible how do i how do
i help
eliminate those those steps that take
you a long time to get up from but do
you think you would have been the
basketball player the man you are if you
had grown up in your environment that
you're in now that your kids are growing
up in
um
if that makes sense to you like what you
where you grow up how you grow up
as opposed to having a little easier
life uh would you have been the same
kind of player do you think
i mean it would have looked a little
different you know i look at someone
like steph curry and steph curry grew up
with his father in the nba you know
obviously grew up having a very great
life uh from from the standpoint of the
the visual of you know successful father
mother and dad together you know in the
family and look at him you know he still
goes out and accomplish things that uh
no one in the game has seen yet and so
if that hunger
um is inside of you to to want to be
great individually if you want something
for your life
um then i don't think i don't think it
matters from that standpoint did the
gangs leave you alone
they did i was covered my family was
my family had some high positions in
games when i was growing up so they kind
of left me alone let me play basketball
how did that work out
well it worked out it worked out good
from from the sense of you know i didn't
have i never had to worry about you know
anything from the standpoint of someone
trying to take advantage of me because
of the family that i grew up in you know
it was more so like oh there's diana
little brother leave him alone
you know my sister had a lot of rank in
the city of chicago and so they didn't
mess with me they didn't mess with our
family a lot were they are they afraid
of your sister
yeah my sister had hands down like
um i want you to play gm we were just
talking about this i'm gonna let you
start your team with
steph
or kd
you get them their entire career
oh
do they both stay healthy their entire
career
their career is their career steph's
been injured kd's been injured
okay oh that's a tough one
i'm gonna go with steph
that's what i went with why did you go
with stuff over kd
well
it does it won't make any sense
you can close your eyes and pick but i
guess i went with steph because steph is
kind of uh revolutionized the sport
you know he's one of those mount
rushmores from the sense of changing the
game um the way he has and so i i give
him that little a little nod do you care
where you're ranked on these list
all-time list i think your espn had the
top 100 your 26th
no i no no no that's all subjective i
mean
you know it depends on what day how do
you wake up was your coffee bitter that
day did you
you know what i mean like i don't i
don't worry about that but you do want
to be named you know for me being named
on the top 75 that was important that
was very important for me to to be
recognized as one of the greatest
players to play the game the the number
that you put people you know that that
right there can be a conversation and
discussion that we would never hear the
end of but to be a part of that that
elite group that's special for me but
you're competitive
like in their part of you that says i
was better than him
no no no because like when you get up to
that level you're you're you're you're
going against guys that you've never you
never played against that you maybe had
a chance to see play you know i mean
that level of greatness these are
players who some players i have never
seen but then i'm right there with like
charles barkley who i got to see play
who i was a huge fan of and thought he
was an amazing player right and so
to me just to be
in that discussion then i come from
nothing i could come from the inner city
of chicago you know really when they say
you don't suppose like how did i get
here i was supposed to be here it's
literally been a lot of things that's
tried to knock me down and not allow me
to you know to be standing here so to be
still standing and to be on that list i
don't care where you put me what was it
like first time you met jordan
first time i met michael jordan um it
was like a it was a scene out of a movie
like i was at i was at my draft party in
chicago
and i'm in the party and i'm dancing my
cousin comes and tapped me on the show
they say hey they won't let michael
jordan in he's outside
then i'm like stop playing with me and
he was like no
look on his face and so we took off we
ran and so i run outside bust through
the doors and michael jordan is sitting
outside on a motorcycle with about 30 or
40 dudes behind him and it's like a
scene out of a movie and i'm walking
closer and closer and i'm like this is
like this is my idol like this is jordan
and he stopped by and he said he just
want to show me some love you know i
just got drafted i'm from the city he
just wanted to show me some love did you
invite him in
i did but he was he was like no no no
they already denied me once
[Laughter]
well we also brought this topic up you
can have charles barkley or tim duncan
i'm taking timmy d yeah and i did too
he liked timmy like timmy liked to pass
he liked to set screens he you know he
charles was trying to get his buckets
but you know the thing is with duncan is
he's so great but he
nobody can remember a signature play
really from him you know he would hit a
turnaround bank shot or he you know he
there was just nothing flashy about him
but he did everything that you would
want a basketball player to do
but people still look at him as a top 10
should he be a top 10 player of all time
well i mean for and i in our generation
as you know power forwards i mean you
know tim duncan kevin garnett like these
guys in our generation i mean they're
the cream of the crop and so you know
the ba i played against him twice in the
finals and the consistency of that guy
the expressions that never
you know the ability just to be able to
like move on to the next thing you know
keep your team no matter if you lost in
the finals getting your team back to the
finals of next year when they played us
in 2013 i mean 2014 i mean just the the
greatness you know of tim duncan as a
leader um i get a chance to experience
it and it's awesome
kevin garnett yell at you on the floor
kevin garnett yells on his self
wait what do you mean he's trying to
fire himself up he gets mad at himself
yeah like i i
first i think a lot of people think like
trash talking and stuff is like because
you see moments on tv when a guy get
into it and maybe they get a technical
foul but like that is they don't that's
so far in between and kg would just talk
to himself and you think he's talking to
you he may be talking about you to
himself
but he talking to himself
[Laughter]
did kobe talk to you
you know what i was you want to tell you
a funny story about kobe when i first
got the nba like one of my idols kobe
bryant and i my 10th game in the nba i
get a chance to play the lakers and i
eventually get switched off on kobe and
i'm guarding him and he's just like
he's just whistling he's just making
like he making little noises and i'm
like you don't even take me seriously
i'm scared
how scary was that when
you know we talk about rhythm shooters
scores and then once they get going it's
like you know you hold on for dear life
yeah i mean you know just guarding kobe
especially at the times where
he wanted to shoot every shot
and they was gonna give him the ball
every play and try to guard him
a lot of my teammates got the switch off
i was like hey d right
but i can't imagine what the raptors
must have felt like when he put up 81.
oh well you know we had to ask chris
bosh about that
[Laughter]
i asked jalen rose every year on the
anniversary of that and he goes i didn't
guard him the whole time i go nobody was
guarding him the whole time
he well i think jayla got like 40. he
got about 40 47.
uh but can i say i love the way that
jalen has just you know jumped into the
the funny of it and the commercial that
coleman and jalen did was it's one of my
favorite sports commercials if you know
that there's ever been just because of
the moment and just like not taking
themselves
who can score 100 points in a game
will we ever have that
i think i think we will um
i don't know when um but it's a lot of
guys that can score 100 points in the
game we got kevin kevin durant can score
100 points in the game like these guys
can score i mean there's so many in the
nba that could fill it up
um you know especially steph curry steph
curry can possibly score 100 points in
the game right but you know the game is
played a little different now guys are
playing way less minutes now um than
they were because the game is so much
faster so but from a talent standpoint
yeah see i see klay thompson maybe
getting it
uh well you could score 60 with like
three dribbles i know
that's pretty pretty amazing if you have
steph out there what's what's your
lebron story that you'll you'll tell
i mean i will have
i'm lucky enough to have plenty right
but i think for me and when i think
about from a basketball standpoint
i just think of i think
if you haven't seen him away from the tv
if you haven't seen him
in practice if you haven't seen him on
off days if you haven't seen him that
way you you don't know the greatness of
this guy you get to see it you get to
see highlights and moments of two hours
of them but if you're behind the scenes
you can see every day of them and that's
the greatness and that's what's special
the way that this guy take care of
himself take care of himself the way
that this guy takes like literally takes
no days off from the sense of he's
either working on his body he's working
on his mind he's working on his game uh
it's just impressive you know i watched
a guy practice you know and do things in
practice that you would never probably
see him do in the game and that's the
way he approached every day so it's so
special what uh
what kind of athlete is your wife
hmm if you let her tell it
we let my wife tell it she's um
she can do all she can quarterback she
can shoot free throws she can she's a
point guard she's he plays soccer
growing up
but ultimately she's just a weekend
warrior that's all she is at this point
yeah
when's the last time you played a pickup
game
i don't know no no i don't play pick up
i don't i don't play basketball you're
done
yeah like i shoot jumpers like with my
son
like i go in the gym and i'm done i
think what's so good about it and what
allows me to be able to be done is that
i do have a son who is in the game
and i'm able to part you know all my
information and my knowledge and my
experience and all my stories he's
willing to listen to him and so i'm
willing to give him all you know all of
my basketball juices because
my body hurt my last couple years my
body was hurt and physically it took a
toll on me mentally it took a toll on me
and uh i don't want that life no more
i'll leave you with this and i don't
know if i ever told you this when i was
handing the uh nba title uh to you uh
you were the mvp shaq's behind me
and shot goes hey
he always he always thought i was craig
sager hey sieger singer let me let let
let me hand the trophy to the little guy
and so shaq grabbed the mv he wanted to
hand you that mvp trophy it meant you
meant that much to him and he wanted
that moment there so i'm so i'm so glad
he did um i remember that moment i
remember
like winning the championship
and being in the back of the line and
everybody was like yo d go to the front
go to the front i'm like why they're
like yo you're about to get mvp
and i remember seeing shaq grab the
trophy and hand it all to me and at that
moment i just remembered everything he
told me like shaq told me i was going to
be one of the greatest to play the game
shaq told me i was one of the best in
the game and for it to be one year after
he came to be able to be hosting a not
only nba championship but a finals mvp
trophy at 24 years old like
thank you pretty good did he ever run
around practice naked
all the time yeah i know
there are a lot of guys who are scarred
for life because shaq would come out and
run around the practice naked
yeah he never got me but he got a lot of
guys
hey uh love the book congratulations and
uh always great to catch up with you
well thank you i appreciate it that
dwyane wade the book it's a photographic
memoir called dwayne it's released today
never before seen photos of his life on
and off the court as he talked about
where he grew up uh inner city chicago